[Music]
I was back in the spring of 2020 it was
clear to us that Biden would be kind of
a hologram candidate conveniently helped
by covid and the D.C press Corps and the
angle told you what the real Dynamic
would be if Biden actually won the
presidency
he's just going to be a figurehead
president
Americans won't be voting for a man who
can articulate a serious policy agenda
let alone defend it
they'll be voting for the party
machine's geriatric puppet
now if you didn't believe me then well
you should now now it's a kind of a
cynical cruel hoax the Democrats are
playing on America because from day one
Joe Biden has been president in name
only our enemies know it and our allies
like the Israeli president in July
they're cringing
and we brought Israelis and Palestinians
together
to get a political level
we need a translation to buy a vowel or
something now people often ask me who's
really in charge at the White House
Laura is it Obama Goldman Sachs the
Pentagon big Tech the donors I always
say who knows but it ain't this guy
nearly 13 million 500 000 jobs just
since you got me sworn in and no in
January of 2020. our secretary of the of
the defense Austin uh secretary Austin
secretary McDonough the Army the
secretary of the army warmer chairman
milley and uh Senator Senator
the senator Blackburn
I thought it was Senator blah for a
moment so aren't the Democrats
embarrassed why do they stick with this
guy because he's wrecked everything he's
touched migrants from his open border
they're overrunning our cities and
inflation it's a nightmare for Working
Families most Americans are a four
hundred dollar unexpected expense away
from bankruptcy
is that a selling point for bionomics by
the way what a great vice president she
is no wonder Biden's numbers are
horrible check out the most recent
Gallup poll only 37 percent somewhat or
strongly approve of his handling of the
economy
but we have to remember Biden the
figurehead he's a perfect president for
the globalist Democrats why is that
because he'll never give the
establishment any pushback not against
the open border not against keeping
wages low not against High Energy prices
certainly not against their Ukraine
policy and not against the trans
insanity and that's just how they like
him compliant
but the voters at least on some of this
stuff they don't agree a new poll shows
that 73 percent of all voters including
two-thirds of the Democrats believe that
Biden's too old for another term
two-thirds of Democrats
yet what's amazing is the party that
claims to be the great guardians of
democracy is itself run by a
dictatorship of the elites
even NBC News is admitting that the
Democratic Elites who hold High office
raise the money and pound the campaign
message that they're all in when it
comes to President Joe Biden's
re-election
in other words what Democrat voters
think or what they want is not relevant
to the party establishment
they readily can see that they hear
doubts about whether Biden is up to the
job their response get over it
get over it
that's how they treat their own voters
no wonder the entire country is such a
mess
there's zero hesitation about running
over their base if that means in the end
that we have higher energy costs that we
have an open border that we have endless
deficit spending
those things by the way are not
accidents those are the actual policies
keep the standard of living low control
the people
but the problem is their policies of
lowering everyone's standard of living
war in Ukraine the attacks on fossil
fuels they're actually hurting the
voters that they desperately need to
turn out to vote
as the New York Times was forced to
acknowledge today noting the marked
deterioration in Mr Biden's support
among registered non-white voters
compared to 2020 it's startling
but again the people pulling Biden's
levers seem to be oblivious about this
for them it's full steam ahead it's
Biden or bust
but there's at least one Democrat in
office who is not afraid to speak the
truth and he's from Minnesota
Congressman Dean Phillips
my call is for the president to pass the
torch I I think that would be in the
country's best interest and certainly
Democrats I'm worried about the five or
six swing States uh the Battlegrounds
that are the most consequential I've
called for some of the moderate
Governors people representing those very
states to consider entering as
alternatives
now Phillips himself considered a run
for about five minutes but then he saw
what was coming down the track at him if
he did so but let's face it all of them
are scared to take on the party
establishment look at what they've
already done to their one celebrated
liberals
I think it's mad for the left to vote
for Cornell West when fascism is at the
door and I think there's something very
wrong with Bobby Kennedy Jr this is a
very dangerous guy with a very storied
name that is casting a dark shadow I
don't consider Marion Williamson to be
much of a threat I think the best way to
handle her is not to address her at all
how convenient the party of free debate
and what's perhaps the most pathetic
development this entire long weekend at
bidens is how the media have become
nothing more than establishment operat
chicks
pummeling the guy with growing minority
support Trump who actually takes on his
party's Old Guard and then propping up
the man protected by the plutocrats who
can't be trusted to find his way off a
stage some people may be disappointed
with Joe Biden but they'll find him more
acceptable than Donald Trump and the
Donald Trump has a ceiling Beyond which
he cannot grow whereas Biden at least
has the potential of bringing people
back home to him
Peter Baker's once a really respected
reporter at the New York Times does he
not read the polls about minority voters
abandoning the Democrat Party
now the fact is so-called journalists
love the Democrat dictatorship
themselves that's actually keeping Biden
right where he is and they like it for
the same reason the same reason they
love mail-in ballots ballot harvesting
proposals for online voting even and the
lockdowns because they don't really
trust the voters not even their own
we the voters have to destroy the
Republican party in order to save it
this is a a chaotic
um uh in many ways authoritarian uh in
cohort kind of of agglomeration uh
that's not really an organized political
party that doesn't really have a
coherent philosophy or governing program
uh except tear it down
Gene tear what down a vibrant economy
immigration enforcement our energy
Independence our history
nope that's what the forces behind Biden
did and are still doing that's the
Fallout from a figurehead presidency and
it's all according to plan whether you
like it or not
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else